can i get your understanding on this
what do you think is happening here what
do you think is motivating these people
do you think it's just a lust of power
or do you think there's something bigger
deeper do you think there's like a you
know a deep state that are organizing
and facilitating or this how do you
quantify everything from your kind of
perspective on the inside so here's the
thing right politicians some of them
maybe half of them love being on tv love
having their name up on the screens and
being the talk of the town and going to
fundraisers and the way you do that is
you sensationalize whatever work is
before you and you take credit for it
main example adam schiff
um
it's partly that and it's partly what am
i going to do next they're always
working for their next job right and
adam schiff's hilarious he wanted to be
the state senator the senator that
replaced kamala harris that didn't
happen he wanted to be the state
attorney general in california that
didn't happen so now this guy's quickly
being the russia gate lead who is being
run out of dc without a job and oh by
the way this guy's a congressman from
hollywood he hasn't lived in hollywood
in a decade he has a house in maryland
with his family
maryland yep
because he works in dc so
yup he can break the law
so
when we look at what the fbi's been
doing right so
withholding evidence targeting
journalists
i don't know if you had any insight in
that stuff but you know luke brought
this up a lot of people like to mention
the deep state or the administrative
state or the bureaucratic state
how would you how would you describe it
i think it's fair to say that there is
something there yeah sure i mean they
were working in collusion all of them
yeah like in line they were they were
pushing the same agenda the same talking
points the same narrative it was it was
like it was like perfect but tell us
about it
yeah sorry i didn't bring it all
together so it's the politicians it's
the media and it's this
quantity of the deep state and i don't
want to i don't want to give it too much
meaning there is a deep state that's
working for with these politicians these
rogue politicians right remember the
whole whistleblower uh for the
russiagate hoax that led to trump's uh
impeachment on ukraine
that was perpetrated by of course none
other than adam schiffin company and he
used the media to say check out this
whistleblower he's got the keys to the
kingdom we're going to prove trump needs
to be impeached
that whistleblower ended up being
someone in government uh in the
intelligence community right and they
combined the forces of the political
realm the media realm and one or two and
big tech because if we say his name this
video the stream will get pulled not
going to say his name but i'm going to
talk about that that's how serious it is
when they're like there's no deep state
whatever i don't care what you call it
when there is a guy who colludes to get
a sitting president impeached and i
can't say his name without youtube
taking the video down maybe you need to
put two and two together and think wow
there are dirty corrupt individuals
working at big tech media and in
politics and here's here's a name we can
say kevin kleinsmith for those that
don't know it right you wanna i know we
keep going back to russia gate kevin
kleinsmith an fbi attorney speaking of
deep state
took a document during the trump russia
gate investigation that was presented
the fisk and changed it he literally
changed it the target of the search
warrant was charter page and he
literally the the the information was
carter page was assisting other
government agencies in the united states
of america you know what he did he took
he literally doctored the document to
say was not
yeah this guy lied got caught by john
durham is a convicted felon now and this
is why people think there is a deep
state because clowns like that can think
i'm going to get away with this because
i got the political top cover from the
likes of adam schiff the media is going
to love me and hero me and somebody's
going to give me a big contract and he
goes on to be convicted but there are
way bigger fish way bigger way bigger
and he gets thrown under the bus because
who is he kevin klein smith yeah he's
some mediocre fbi attorney and that's
what i tell people i'm like do you think
this guy perpetrated the biggest hoax in
american history on his own what about
the meeting with uh was it comey sally
yates
um the 25th thing yeah obama was there
too wasn't he
oh no no that was right before trump got
in i think that's right talking they all
met together and comey uh you know there
was there was the letter he was taking
notes yeah and obama's like do
everything by the book i think was the
message and susan rice was in that
meeting and she wrote this classified
email that took me two years to
declassify and when it finally came out
it showed that basically they were
trying to set up an income president she
basically like wrote herself an email
exonerating herself yeah i didn't do
anything wrong right all these people
did
what do you think about chuck schumer's
comments when he kind of gave a veil
threat to donald trump saying that if
you mess with the intelligence agencies
they have seven ways to sunday in order
to get back at you
i mean that was a big statement a lot of
people were wondering what what does he
mean by that he's very connected to of
course the intelligence committee so he
has a lot of play and a lot of sway
how was your kind of reaction to that
i'm offended i mean as a guy who was in
the intelligence community who used it
to target terrorists around the world
who used it to i was a deputy director
of our national intelligence community
right as a guy who ran and said we
should focus on threats that matter iran
china russia terrorists bringing home
hostages things that matter to the
president
to say that we're gonna then threaten to
take these guys off mission
to target people who
colluded with russia
is offensive to me and everybody that i
worked with and i and i know there's a
lot of people that are still in
government that feel that way because
i'm still friends with them but when you
have one of those most powerful
politicians in america say that it only
weakens our apparatus and you know what
we're focusing on now joe biden goes to
g20 and he's talking about the weather
yeah
do you think uh there's going to be some
kind of national divorce or
dissolution of the united states
a lot of people i know man and i guess
maybe i'm uh i'm just uh i'm in love
with the the idea of america too much um
that that i can see that happening being
a son of an immigrant actually my dad
actually fled a genocidal dictator and
lived the american dream and then
watched his son go work in the white
house i think maybe that ride has given
me too much faith in the system and i'd
still like to think that it'll succeed i
don't like to be too pessimistic or you
know blackpilled as it were but like
everything we talk about the story about
these corrupt individuals pushing these
lies for years and getting away with it
for the most part we'll see how many of
them are going to get in continually get
indicted
and then you have just the culture
conflict the culture war itself you have
the different states joe biden says you
know he comes out earlier this year like
we're going to need more mandates
clearly not talking to red states where
texas and florida were doing the exact
opposite you got the report out of last
year from the boston globe that john
podesta was he was he the head of the
hillary campaign yes 2016.
said he and
they reported he encouraged the west
coast to secede from the union in the
event donald trump wins
look man i know you're right look at
look at virginia the republicans swept
this off-cycle election really really
well state we had a trucker in new
jersey this is the best spend 153 bucks
and beat the incumbent democrat who's
refusing to concede saying like no no
i'm not going to lose it's trucker's
like oh wow i guess i won people were so
anti-established at this point they're
so anti-democrat they're like i'll vote
for literally whoever the republican is
so come 2022
republican tsunami come 2024 another
republican presidency are these are the
democrat operatives gonna be like oh all
that stuff we said about wanting to
secede
we've changed our minds now that we've
lost no they're not gonna do that
they're just gonna have the media carry
their water again and just like shift
topic and say we never said that this is
what we're focusing on now china russia
trump you know the trump russia
conclusion narrative 2.0 and the sales
kid will probably be uh pumping in and
the republican party will sit on their
hands and say okay
nothing our leadership look i agree with
you man our leadership having worked in
congress look i went at it with paul
ryan at it when i was on the house intel
committee i told i took me four months
to convince that guy to give me a
subpoena so i could prove to the world
that hillary clinton paid for the
dossier four months and when i did and i
went back to him and i didn't do an
exactly i told you so but i was like how
about the other subpoenas so i can get
to work on behalf of the american public
but i think it's because people like
paul ryan the establishment republicans
yes no different from the establishment
democrats it's the unicorn totally and
and you know i view it as donald trump
was the insurgent candidate who stormed
his way in and he brought in some good
people he didn't fire enough of the bad
people that's it yeah no no that's it
people ask me how how do you fix it the
next go around
the bench personnel matters and i think
what president trump did was he
entrusted too much of the careers in
government to be like no no this is john
bolton yeah he was sitting down with
henry kissinger before he even got into
austin we could talk we could talk about
millie but uh i think they learned their
lesson and i think they know and the
bench exists the bench exists of people
and when i came into it i wasn't
i wasn't a political guy and trump is
not this like neo-conservative you know
guy he's basically like
in the middle yeah i mean that and i
grew up with the guy in new york so i
got it i understood it well he
flip-flopped between like a globalist
and a patriot which he even called
himself that
uh but but to kind of continue the
conversation we talk about the media a
lot how do you view the media do you see
them as kind of these vultures these
kind of energy vampires these kind of
demons mere merchants or do you not the
tim pool show
no work or do you see them as agents
that are controlled because there is
some circumstantial evidence suggesting
that the intelligence agencies do spin
off the mainstream media do write
certain scripts do insert stories and
narratives that are centrally uh kind of
uh written and narrated for the
mainstream media to follow so so how's
the how are the intelligence agencies uh
working with the media because there's
there's so much circumstantial evidence
unfortunately i'll go one step further
it's not circumstantial it's direct look
we see and have seen in the last five
years the leak of classified information
to substantiate a false media narrative
over and over again that's a felony
releasing classified i'll give you a
perfect example rush not russia gate
russia bounty gate right okay oh yeah a
year and a half or two years ago it was
said that this information was given out
to i don't know if it was washington
post or wherever it was but basically
saying president trump was aware that
putin was taking american money to have
american soldiers killed yeah i mean
just hit pause on that for a second how
offensive is that when if you're serving
in the u.s military
we at the time i think i was deputy
director of national intelligence i knew
the intelligence we didn't go out and
leak the actual intelligence just to
correct the record because a that's a
felony it's illegal fast forward a year
what happens under the biden
administration the intelligence
committee comes out and says oh actually
we got that one wrong sorry and of
course the people that wrote about it
didn't uh didn't change their tune but
that's a direct example of how the media
perpetrates a fraud at the behest of
their political overlords yeah and then
there's there's a lot of lies told by
anonymous kind of government agents and
then every time i see you know
government spokesperson or
representative from the government i'm
like i doubt that story officially i
mean we had the syrian gas attacks that
were again put in in a huge question
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you